growing medicinal plants in your own
backyard is
easy and accessible it's a great way
to be more self-sufficient and to take
control of your health options
hi i'm celeste i'm a mama 5 and an
astrologer
and i use plant medicine for myself my
family
and my clients i also happen to grow a
lot of that medicine
right here in my own backyard so today
i'm going to take you around my garden
and show you how easy it is to grow your
own medicine
in your backyard and how that can
benefit you let's get started
so what are medicinal plants how do you
use them
and why would you want to grow them well
medicinal plants can be a lot of things
you would be surprised
at what is classified as medicinal and
this is because the plant's medicine
can be in its seeds it can be in flowers
the leaves
the roots the bark or even the fruit it
can be used for both acute
and chronic conditions for example this
rosemary right here you can use this in
a tea
in order to treat a headache right now
or you can also use other things to
treat migraines over the long term
plant medicine is holistic that means it
treats the whole
self so it does this by supporting major
organ function
it restores hormonal imbalances
it also counteracts stress and it takes
mental health into consideration for a
whole
package treatment but you can also use
it just to help somebody feel better if
they have a cold
or maybe they got bitten by an insect
and plant medicine is really great for
everyone all the way from children
up until the elderly and another great
thing about growing medicinal plants
is that you don't really need a lot of
space when i first
moved here three years ago this bed
right here was the only one i had
and it was all that i needed to provide
for my family's needs
i had some things in the sunny area and
some things in the shady area
and over the course of a few seasons i
was able to
get a well-stocked apothecary in my home
and you can do the same thing
the great thing about herbs is that once
you prepare them properly and store them
properly
they can last for several months up to
several years depending on what
preparation you use
and so you can go collecting little by
little if you have a small space
and medicinal plants are great to grow
because they're hardy survivors and they
often grow like weeds
in fact even if you aren't growing
anything in your garden yet
you might already be growing medicine if
your yard is full of weeds
in one of rob's recent videos he talks
about 11
edibles that you can find growing wild
around your garden or yard
and a lot of the edibles that he
mentions in that video are also wild
medicinals
so it's all about looking at your land
as he says
and looking at it from a different
perspective so right here for example i
have some spanish needle
so this is a wild edible that grows all
over the place here in florida
but also you can use the flowers in a
tea
for cough so this is a really great way
for you to look at your yarn from a
different perspective
and see what medicine you might already
be growing in your yard and then just
tend to those medicinals
and growing medicinal plants in your
yard is actually very easy
there are some of the least finicky
plants to grow
rob recently put out another video
that's a beginner tips
for gardeners to have a successful
garden and if you check that out that's
going to tell you pretty much everything
you need to know
if you apply those to your herbal garden
it should do really really well
but there are a few things that are
unique to growing herbal medicine
so first of all you want to make sure
that you're growing the right variety
so there's a lot of different varieties
of plants for example marigolds
there's a lot of different marigolds
that are just
ornamental and so you might not have the
one that is specifically the
medicinal calendula flower that you're
looking for
so you can have this a sweet basil or
you can also have holy basil or
tosi and so both of these are called
basil both of them have medicinal
properties but they're not the same so
you just have to make sure that you
don't let common names confuse you
and that you're looking at the latin
name to make sure that you're picking
the right species for you one other
thing about growing medicinal plants
that's really important
is knowing when to pick the medicine at
the right time
so for example you might have something
where you're going to pick the leaves in
the spring
and then you're going to pick the
flowers in the summer and then finally
you'll
pick the roots in the fall so you need
to know exactly when to pick what so
that you can
gather your medicine at the most optimal
time
so that it can be properly used so let's
talk prep and storage because that's one
of the
biggest parts of having your own
medicinal plants in your backyard is
using them
so you can use things fresh that's fine
fresh is great for anything that has for
example a soup or a tea
a poultice or a compress anything like
that would be great to use
fresh herbs with them you can also
freeze your herbs to use in teas or to
do medicinal soups i like to blend the
herbs with garlic
and use that in a medicinal soup that's
really great
but for the other things like oils and
tinctures and vinegars you're going to
want to have
your herbs dried and you can do this in
a few different ways
you can do little bundles uh you can
dry the flowers and just put them face
down and you can
just hang them up or you know i have
something like this
where i just lay the flowers inside and
have them dry and the main thing is you
just want to make sure to keep the
bundle small
and to keep a lot of space in between
the flowers to promote good air
circulation
and also make sure that it's in a warm
dry place
that doesn't have a lot of humidity and
after a few days
you want to check on your things
depending where you live how long it
takes to dry then
you want to take them down and put them
into containers like this and label them
and also preferably put a date on them
so you can use them within their optimal
time frame
and then once they're dried like this
you can put them together with
oil or even with say alcohol like i've
done here
and you can make medicinal oils you put
the herbs in
with the oil and you let them sit for
about a month shaking them once a day
and then you would strain out the herbs
and you'll be left with something like
this
that you can use you can use this as is
or
you can use this to create butters or
balms or salads or things like that
then you also for the tinctures this is
really good because this is made with
alcohol
and so these last a really really long
time so it's a really great way to build
your
home medicine cabinet it also packs a
lot of
medicine in a really small amount so if
you have somebody that
doesn't like the way it tastes then this
is really great to mix
into a glass of water or maybe even hide
it in a smoothie that's a really great
option too
and it's also long lasting like i said
so you can make these uh tinctures and
then they can last you for
many years so i hope that this has given
you some inspiration to get started on
growing medicinal plants
in your own backyard and i'm really
excited to hear if you'll give this a
[Music]
try